passing over Arctic ice sheets a
commercial satellite sees nothing but a
blanket of white until it captures
protruding from the ice part of a
concrete structure in the middle of
nowhere there's more polar bears than
people it's a barren wasteland there's
ice and mountains but in the middle we
see this strange structure the looks as
if it's some sort of underground bunker
or lair this reminds me of Superman and
the fortress of solitude you know aliens
hiding this you know upload Center for
Superman to figure out where he's from
so the question is what are they doing
there science writer Joe Pappalardo
investigates the image and spots that
the structure has a road leading to a
door anytime you see it a road that
leads into a tunnel no exit you wonder
what are they housing in there what's
actually being held inside of that
facility the structure glimpsed by the
satellite is the entrance to an
underground vault a bunker to be used in
the event of a global apocalypse there
are 15,000 atom bombs in the world
enough to threaten the human race with
extinction the US and other governments
are prepping for a disaster on the scale
of a nuclear holocaust
there's all sorts of ways for life to
end on earth whatever happens the reason
we'll die is starvation we won't die
because of the nuclear fire we won't die
from the fallout as a species
we'll die because we can't grow enough
food to live satellite cameras have
captured the entrance to an apocalypse
survival bunker aimed at saving the
human species turns out that the turn of
the millennium the Norwegians as well as
the United Nations began this project to
build a massive Seed Vault in case
anything really really bad happened to
the planet the vault is currently
storing more than 900 thousand samples
of plant life but it can store up to
four point five million varieties in 2.5
billion seeds this seed vault is like
the Noah's Ark but for plants if a
global nuclear war wipes out most of
humanity the few survivors will have the
seed tools to reinvent basic agriculture
all they have to do is find the bunker